I don't know anything about this guy
random video narcissist and stand with
Ukraine posted in March look at these
people yeah they're so upset about
Ukraine I'm sure they're stupid looking
outfits have nothing to do with while
they're out there right look I painted
my hand and put a seashell over my see
how much I care no war I'm crying yeah
nothing says you're devastated like
spending your entire day preparing for a
fashion shoot on a sidewalk what kind of
people are these
no war in Ukraine now that must be the
vomit pail for everyone who sees through
your [ __ ]
[Music]
well that's one way to use the Bloodshed
of ukrainians to get more followers on
Tick Tock will you be doing a follow-up
tutorial video for other aspiring mass
murder makeup artists like yourself I
need help well yeah I mean if you're
posting vanity photos under pray for
Ukraine and every other hashtag you
could think of that's related to war I'm
sure you do need help at least you're
aware you have a problem I'll give you
that can't say the same for this bozo
it's heartbreaking to hear what is going
to happen yeah well I'm scared of what's
going to happen in in Western Europe too
yeah you know you just you plan a trip
you want to go there I want to go to
Italy for four years I haven't been able
to make it because of of uh the pandemic
jet because of Vladimir Putin did she
actually just say she's scared about you
know she plans to trip and she's gonna
have to enter a trip you want to go
there I want to go to Italy for four
years I haven't been able to make it
because of of uh the pandemic and now
this yeah distraught because she can't
go on vacation now you know it's like
who's gonna what's gonna happen there
you should call Ukraine and ask him to
apologize for the inconvenience go for a
cruise to the Bermuda Triangle instead
I'm sure they'll be glad to pay for it
dear President Vladimir Putin now this
should be good I'm so sorry that I was
not your mother if I was your mother you
would have been so loved
held in the arms of joyous light never
would the stories plight the world
unfurled no you gotta stop this you
really shouldn't have recorded this I
mean did you think this was gonna fall
into the category of doing something I
mean what did you expect to accomplish
by this you think he's watching this in
the war room like
I cannot believe I was born too late in
a different place when someone sat in
front of a camera filmed this watched it
before she spent an hour doing her hair
and then posted it online she probably
tried out four different shirts looked
at in the mirror and I was like you know
what I'm gonna go with the turtleneck
yeah
everything and then she's now she's is
this it like is this is this an audition
is this this made me this is an audition
she's so corny like maybe she's an
actress in Hollywood this is an audition
tape and she just wants to ReDiscover
this is why I can't be this can't be
serious there's no way a grown woman
broke up and did this on purpose that's
why I'm out of this bit I'm out of this
country for years sometimes as I'm sure
everyone including May is thinking about
the situation in Ukraine are you because
right now you're showing us a photo of
yourself that you're trying to pass off
as you thinking about Ukraine when in
reality it's you showing us your shitty
tattoo how do I know this because your
arm is always positioned to perfectly
display in nearly every photo you take
let's play finish the tone deaf virtue
signal as an effort to help people in
Ukraine during the Ukraine Invasion I
will be having a food and clothing
donated to each region of Ukraine
starting tomorrow B charity event to
raise money for the people of Ukraine or
see a sale on my only fans at 50 off for
everyone in Ukraine now if you chose C
you'd be correct you'd also be in the
majority considering most people know
that people who take mirror selfies with
their phone covering their face have yet
to be documented contributing anything
to humanity aside from promo codes and
50 off you couldn't even give it to them
for free and you cream they can't even
buy food and stuff and you're giving
them oh you don't have to pay 20 a month
you get to pay ten dollars a month that
is that's atrocious no the fact that
she's promoting herself at all is
atrocious oh my God that isn't hard-ons
I've been avoiding posting on Instagram
no you haven't I feel guilty no you
don't I feel helpless no you don't
friends and their families are going
through the worst days of their lives
right now there's nothing I can do but
support them the only way I know how to
by sharing a photo of my ass on vacation
on a beautiful day what an honorable
thing to do I'm sure when the people
suffering see this they'll thank you for
sharing a photo of you doing absolutely
nothing you just said in your caption
Make Love Not War well that's a
wholesome moment you make love with your
kid in the bed well if that's the case I
declare war against both of you until
that kid's removed from your custody
what's wrong with you people are we done
or do you want to do one more no no I
want to go eat something 10 minutes no
you said that 10 minutes ago I feel like
like you're the parent and I'm the kid
now
when you were little and you were like
let's go and I was like I know I'm just
saying goodbye to one more person I know
oh my God and yeah and then you make me
run upstairs and then I end up having to
stand next to you and then I just run
off again for another three hours while
you're saying goodbye the university
drops soon it's going into all my social
media knowledge how to monetize social
media make a living off of it this is
what I've done for the last couple years
so now I'm teaching people kind of cool
I think in the first thousand people get
in it for a crazy discount mom's making
a section in the University it's gonna
be dope
[Music]